I think the world has gotten very good
at selling fear and hate and I want to
sell practical optimism I'm not
delusional I'm a very practical operator
this is not like the secret like sit at
home and pray that you'll be a
professional skier that [ __ ] doesn't
work what does work is hey if you love
skiing believe it or not try to make
some skiing videos on Tick Tock and see
what the world does with it you'll never
believe what it can happen and I know it
to be true because at this point 15
years into this journey hundreds of
thousands of emails from people that
have taken one piece of content done it
and something good has happened whether
it's as simple as hey Gary we really got
into the garage sale stuff that you were
telling us our family likes it we have a
lot of fun on Saturdays but we made
eight thousand dollars on the side and
now we can afford this Disney trip thank
you that's profound that is a profound
life change and so yes I push it I push
it on my own employees I want people to
be happier because the net of that is a
good thing